[Music]
hello how are I I am greeted and today I
bring you today's most outstanding headlines
Tuesday December
22 long lines are expected
at the coronavirus testing sites in the
valley before Christmas Eve and Christmas
here is a list of  some of the sites
that will be offering tests
today the judo senior center without going
to have near leitner and
martin luther king streets as well
as the university carmen center and the
south nevada health center are also
offering tests  And today is the last
day for small businesses to apply
for federal funds with Clark County.
The funds are not a loan
but a grant that seeks to help
small businesses with less than 50
employees pay rent,
utilities, salaries, among other business expenses.
they can receive up to 30 thousand
dollars to apply you can visit the
page news joe dotcom and the impact of
the pandemic continues to be felt and  In the
tourist zone of the city, the hotel,
the casinos and hotels that will close their
operations on weekdays and open only
from Thursday to Sunday in November, the
hotel along with the mandalay bay and the
park also announced adjustments to their
hotel operations on weekdays this
adjustment  It includes the closure of restaurants
, game tables and other attractions such as
the volcano as of January 4 and
while some hotels adjust their
operations
others are reopening to the public the
hotel rio opened this morning after
almost 10 months of being closed due to
the pandemic  The property expects to
reopen its gaming tables and
slots areas throughout the week as
well as its restaurants, canteens and the
gym but the hotel itself is only
accepting reservations from Thursday to
Monday now we move on with
the weather forecast another day is expected  sunny and
above normal we will begin to lower
the temperatures for tomorrow we will be
in the 50 degrees as well there will be n  ubes and
winds for the rest of the week
have a good day I am salt and jara you hear me
Spanish edition
[Music]